presentations today and we're going to
get started with uh jalen patel and
um
he is an intern who worked with us at
the kci institute informatics group
and um
i just want to recognize i was his
mentor but also that way chun lin
also um worked a lot uh with helping him
uh with coding in different libraries
and stuff to do this work and with the
prior work that we
have done in this area so i'd like to
introduce jalen he is a rising senior at
clackamas high school and he's very
interested in tech and he did a great
job with our group this summer so
um jalen after you
thank you michelle um i
am jalen patel hello everyone um yeah so
i was an intern um this summer and today
i'm going to be out the research i
performed um
a application of unsupervised machine
learning methods to define clinical
phenotypes among no show and show
pediatric ophthalmology patients
um yeah as michelle said i'm a rising
senior
i was born in antonio texas and grew up
in portland oregon
in both
gresham and clackamas and i've been by
data science for a long time
um and i plan to major in computer
science and college
so like
interesting and
um really happy to have both this
project and excited excited to share it
with you
no shows arguments where people don't
show up and it didn't cancel
ahead of time they're a pro problem
because they affect clinic efficiency as
well as the continuity
continuity of patient care and also
medical clinics really want a full
schedule
we know from
previous literature why patients might
not show um and this is also motivation
for our study a lot of it has to do with
what's going on in patients lives
whether it's the work schedules or other
conflicts that come up
but it can also relate to their
attitudes towards the health towards
their health care and also whether or
not they they feel they're being
respected and their time is being
respected by the healthcare system and
some of them may think that they're
going to wait a long time and that they
don't have time for that and also they
might not understand that when they
don't show there isn't someone else that
takes their appointment and so this
information
um is more qualitative and it doesn't it
still doesn't help us figure out who's
gonna come or not because we don't
really store this type of data about our
patients
um so but what we do know about our
patients is essentially what's in the
ehr um so we want to see if we can use
what's in the ehr to help us figure out
this information
um so in our study um
we define these clinical phenotypes
using the available hr data for both no
show and show patients in the pediatric
ophthalmology specialty at kci institute
and our project was much in their use of
existing hr data and we can actually use
this um for developing future studies of
interventions or future engineering to
help reduce notional rates
and so in past um there has been a work
by um
by jimmy chen from ohsu and this was a
supervised learning model um where they
both did they had two models of both um
follow-up visits and new patients and
for the follow-up visits um
um the best performance model was the xj
boost model and
you know the um the auc roc score for
that
uh was 0.9 and the position recall score
was 0.74
while for the new patients
the best performance model was the lasso
regression model um
and
auc score was 0.74 while the precision
recall was 0.27
but in this study um there are a few
limitations um
just based on it being supervised
learning um that unsupervised learning
could help with
first we were able
first um in the supervised learning we
we're able to do some feature analysis
but all we can figure out is how
important a feature is we can't figure
out you know if that feature is more
indicative of one outcome or the other
or
um
and we just know like it's important for
example if you found out that medicaid
was important
you don't really know if that means you
are more or less likely to have a
no-show if you have that insurance
and the second limitation is that
for new patients it doesn't do a very
good job because a lot of the
unsupervised learning models are based
on the previous history of the patient
like number of previous cancels or
number of previous no-shows and so new
patients don't have this frequent wizard
information so it's a little bit harder
to make the correct prediction with um
with supervised learning
and so on other hand unsupervised
learning methods help us reveal new
patterns and really figure out
phenotypes about our patients
and it also doesn't need a human to
label data for training
and both of um
these unsurprisingly supervised learning
um are both part of machine learning and
they both help divide data into groups
and the difference between them is that
supervised learning uses labels and
unsupervised learning looks for the
general
outcome
and so that brings us to our data set um
this data um was uh from epic for
patient visits occurring between 2012
to 2018 for seven pg active
ophthalmologists
and um we really focused on the no-show
status of the most recent visit
occurring between 2015 to 2018
per patient because if
if we use the data from the first half
then um
we don't know if we would have enough
data to populate um the historical
features of our data set
uh so um the features um we selected in
this data set
um both that were already in the ehr or
that we
um or that were manipulated to um
for us to use
um the
the we use both categorical features as
in there's a certain there's a set
number of categories that um you know
the feature has and then continuous
features where it's numerical and um
it yeah so it's just usually the number
of and the categorical features we
divide into demographic um
insurance and appointment
um while the continuous uh
uh features are more about the
historical you know
behavior of the patient during 2012
uh 2002 2018
and the categorical features are more
about the notion status of the visit
i'm clustering
so um there were three models that we um
uh went through uh and um tested in the
study and the first was k-means where we
could um you use only the continuous uh
variables of the data set the second was
key modes where we used the categorical
um variables in the data set
and then lastly three prototypes where
we can use both the continuous and the
categorical variables
uh the way um we
we wanted to figure out how many
clusters are best for classing
and um in this example right here um
this is just with other data not with
the data we use in the study but you can
see how it works and how in this we're
testing out four clusters
and you can see that it's the optimal
number because um the widely apart and
the um
and
the
the bars for each of the clusters is
different
and the way we evaluated which model
would be the best to use is the adjuster
and index as well as the accuracy
um
for the adjusted rand index
we
the equation for that is r equals a plus
b
over nc2
and a um
would be the number of times actual
notional status and cluster labels were
the same while b would be the number of
times the actual inertial status and
cluster variables were not the same and
c2 would be the number of unordered
pairs in a set of n elements um and so
the absolute value of ari
is uh is
is what's important not if it's negative
or positive
and for accuracy that's just a
proportion of the total number of
predictions that are correct
and
um and so it's matched labels over total
visits
and because we're trying to determine
how well the data clusters we're only
looking at which metrics need made sense
so a lot of people might not be familiar
with their i score so we measure
accuracy as well to help you visualize
it better
and this accuracy um
as well as the ari will tell you how
well the clusters matched up with the
no-show outcomes just so we could see
um just
just so we can
see that
and so on to the results of our study um
how many clusters are ideal uh we
found that two clusters are best for
class of fragmentation visits um as you
can see
um
there three could also be a possible
choice um
um
two
um
is because in the in the graph with
three
uh two of them were very similar
even though in some of the other graphs
you could see like two three separate
um three
bins
um
and so the ideal number of clusters uh
is going to be two
in terms of the algorithm performance um
we measured
that k modes
was
better
because a lot of the
like
the both the accuracy was 70.6 percent
which is the highest as well as the ari
um
0.046 was also the highest
and so it did a really nice job um
because 70 is actually
uh
a high score um in terms of accuracy and
we also like also a lot of the
continuous data um might also be hard to
get into the system in real time because
you have to let's extract other pieces
of other other pieces of data and then
calculate it based off of that
and the paragon features we discussed
earlier are easier to find in epic so in
the future we could
potentially make unsurprised learning
models um based on only these
categorical features
and so um you can see here a kind of
distribution of um how they how the
labels that we
clustered and also the actual labels um
match together
this is like a confusion matrix or
crosstab and we um this one is just
based on the best model in terms of
performance
which was key modes and so you can see
in this first subgroup um
we have a higher proportion of no-show
patience
um because it's uh 3 18
um
out of
1589 versus 6 40 out of 49 14
and
um and so if we
add the
318 patients in the first subgroup as
well as the 4
to
274 show patients in the second subgroup
we get that high accuracy accuracy score
of 70 70.6
and so we basically label these um
label these clusters accordingly to that
and
there are characteristics um
uh that
we can we
could um figure out you know
which character which characteristics
are associated with which um you know
phenotype of patient but there's no show
or show and so in terms of the weekday
we found that um
most of as you can see on the graph uh
there are higher percentage of no-show
patients on thursday while um there are
the the highest percentage of show
patients are on tuesday
and this is um the age group and
a school age for
school age patients are the highest
group um
that are no show
or show i mean sorry and
toddler is the highest
um
is the highest percentage of patients
who are no-show
and
patients who are no show
in terms of their insurance type we
found that they were
almost 80 percent were on
medicaid oregon um
and
we also found that
um
over 50
of the commercial patients um you know
showed up to showed up to their
appointments
uh the primary provider um also had a
impact on the
uh on the patient no show status um
because in you as you can see in
for provider g
we can see over 30 percent um of the
patients were no show
um well for provider e um
uh
more than 20 of the patients
showed up to their appointment
gender
could also have a factor
based on these findings
in
the mail group um
they were almost eighty percent uh
no-shows
um
while in the female group they were uh
sixty percent
or uh show um
show patients
um in the diagnosis um
the takeaway from this is we
uh we
can't really um
you know make conclusions about this yet
because there are too many missing
diagnoses in the data set um and you
might see like none is the highest but
they're also
you know different things like the you
know the provider didn't put a primary
diagnosis um but they do have other
diagnosis um so there's a lot of
um
there there isn't enough information
that we can make a conclusion
and so this as a as a summary of the
phenotype of neutral patients and show
patients as you could see
that most of the uh
the
phenotype that we could use for the
no-show patients is that they have their
appointment on thursday um they're in
the toddler age group
they have medicaid oregon insurance plan
they are seeing primary provider g and
they are male and for the show patients
phenotype we could
make for them is that they
are
they have their appointment on tuesday
um their school age they have commercial
insurance they are seeing primary party
a and they're female
and on this slide um i wanted to show
how this compared to our
to the unsupervised um study that was
done earlier um like i said um in in
that study we
found we found some pad um we found uh
a few uh
one or two patterns um similar
unsurprised learning compared to
supportive learning but most of it i
found in the study was new information
for example um
the inch
for example the age toddler was in both
was both an important feature in
supervised learning
as well as for notional patients um
in our model
um but remember that
we can only find out um the phenotype of
in the
um unsupervised learning model rather
than the supervised learning because the
supervisor is only going to tell you
if a if a feature is important um
or not
and how important how important it is
and you might notice that some of these
variables um in the supervised learning
are our features and some of them are a
specific category of future
of a feature um the reason for that is
that they had to one-hot encode the
categorical variables um in that study
so
um
there's a
for the categorical variable there's a
separate
column for each
each category
and so a brief summary of key findings
we've we found that two clusters are
ideal for the data set
key modes is the algorithm with the best
performance
seventy percent of the visits um
were correctly matched between the
cluster label and notion label in k
modes um
uh we found that day a week um the age
group
um
their insurance type
the primary provider and the gender are
most different between the subgroups
the no show patient phenotype um
would have an up no
like a no-show patient
in just in terms of the phenotype would
have an appointment on tuesday would be
school age um
has a
medicaid oregon insurance plan uh
issuing primary prodigy and his mail and
attending and a show patient would have
an appointment on tuesday would be
school age they would have um commercial
insurance they would be seen primary
corrected day and they would be female
i also wanted to address the limitations
that um
that our study had
first and the study was performed at a
single institution for a single
specialty and previous work suggests
that notion models perform best when
trained on a clinic level rather than on
a combination of data sets
also pediatrics is a specialty where
patients are often broadened by the
parent
and in this data that we had we
put in um include variables related to
the parent
and the third is that the sample size
was small uh 600 6503 visits
and um
when the sample size is small it could
reduce the power of the study and
increase the margin of error um
and the population we study with most
was mostly white um which isn't
representative of which isn't
representative of diagram scripts
so in conclusion um unsupervised machine
learning can be used to successfully
develop phenotypes or no show and show
patients in pediatric ophthalmology
this is just an initial step to
understanding um these phenotypes so
that we can start to study which
interventions make more sense and this
will provide
base level knowledge for future study so
for instance future studies might use
categorical variables only or
um or something else
that we um we found in this study
and
some
examples of patient positive
interventions are like calling or
texting them a month week or day in
advance to make sure they're coming or
if you if we should cancel it and then
if they have to cancel we can book
another patient so we can effectively
reduce no show rates that way
awesome so in this internship
i really learned a lot um from my mentor
michelle and wai chun
i first learned a lot about pandas as a
data science and
manipulation tool
as well as machine learning models
and also how we can use data science and
medicine and health and how to come up
with research questions and
um
and what we
what kind of
um
what kind of things we can find out in
terms of medicine
by using data data informatics and
we um also
i also learned a lot about um
revaluating and potentially restricting
metal method
because a lot of times we have to change
plans based on whatever circumstance
comes up um and so the research study
doesn't go the way that we wanted it to
and
uh
with code 19 it was very different than
being in person as usual um and
so you definitely have to learn to adopt
a new environment as well as um when you
have this like project it makes like it
might seem really straightforward but
there were um but with so many parts it
can be hard to keep track of and
organizing it so i definitely was able
to gain skills in that
as well as writing up my results and
giving this full
culminating presentation um putting
together everything i didn't learn um
and also how we can analyze outcome
measures
um
to reduce health inequities and and
using the hr data to optimize clinical
workflow and make you know the physician
and the
um
and their job everybody working the
clinic's
job easier
i do i really would like to thank uh dr
michelle farber um for uh uh for all her
help throughout the summer and her
immense support um i also want to thank
dr wychen lin for your feedback in each
step of the research process and keeping
me very busy and giving me new tasks to
complete
i want to thank oregon health and
science university for this opportunity
as well as the dmx department
i also want to thank andrea
for leading this internship program and
i just want to thank national library
medicine for making this internship
possible
and thank you everyone for allowing me
to give this presentation um and i'm
open for questions thank you so much
thank you jalen um
i was wondering uh
what would
you do next if you could continue uh
working in this area what will be the
next thing you would want to study or
extend the
research to do
good question i think um i
would
probably um
well is it um
this study or another study like
extending this study or
is it um
like a whole new study
i think it either extending the study or
doing something related to it um
yes um for
um
this um
for
this study um
or for
yeah for this study i i would probably
like extend the study to
um
to actually um
make
um
and make that
into more of
um used in the clinical setting and try
to um use the on like the supervised
learning as well as the unsupervised
learning to
uh further refine our further refine
like our findings and try to
um
like develop those interventions like i
said um
that
we
um
yeah and then reevaluating that based on
what we what we see in the clinic
happening
and um
and how we can improve uh and how we can
improve um like
the
the models um predict model predictions
and
in the classifications of the models
great thank you
well
if there aren't any other questions i
think we can move on to the next
presentation so it looks like is anita
are you going to introduce
i am
yeah
okay so well
gabrielle's bringing up her slides um so
i just want to introduce you to the next
three speakers um it's been a pleasure
working with the interns this summer um
they have participated in internship
with the center for data health on the
national kovic cohort collaborative um
this effort involves over
2 600 people from across the nation and
500 organizations
um so the three interns have have all of
them have different backgrounds and
experience and their undergrads and high
school students which has been terrific
and um the purpose of the internship was
to expose them um to learn about various
aspects of data science as data science
is a very broad field
especially in a team science environment
and to help understand you know what
it's like to work work with a
centralized electronic health record
resource that we have data from various
institutions um so this summer they've
collaborated with a number of different
researchers across the country um to
learn different aspects about data
science and they've been great to work
with and so when introduced the first
speaker
um which is gabriella um tan killerson
and gabriella i'm apologizing for
misspending
at portland state university and so um
she's going to be there for speakers
today
all right give me a second
um
y'all can see
my slides
yeah we can see them
oh no
great um justice lights correct
yes only the slides oh great
um
[Music]
right uh so hello as anita said i'm
gabriella thank gillison uh he was
pronounced correctly
um and
she said i
i am an undergrad at portland state
university
and
uh this summer i had the opportunity to
intern with the
national uh coved court
collaborative um initiative
um and during my internship i worked
with anita walden uh
the assistant director of
cd2h and
uh amy alex who is the
team lead for npc's immunosuppressed and
compromised domain team
so just a little bit of background about
uh
n3c um is the ndc's initiative is to uh
bring together a variety of
scientists from around the
country as anita said
and to be an open science community to
analyze patient-level data and answer
questions related to covet 19.
so um
n3c receives their data from various
institutions from all around
the country um
well related with the cova 19 related
data
and of course this data is
um ahr data um
and so the data from all the
institutions
uh populates into uh npcs data enclave
um which of course as i just mentioned
is the hr data
and
while
the
uh the data enclave is obviously the
place for um
where the data populates
one thing i want to note about they did
enclave is that it is also a community
environment
for the scientists that have
access to the data enclave they work
together with other teams
and other individuals so it's a
community environment as well
and
last thing about um
ntc that i want to
introduce our domain teams
um a domain team with the nvc is a group
of individuals that centers their
research around a
particular area or population topic
um and relate
that
area to their findings of the coven 19
data that they
utilize from the
data enclave
and so before i
talk about
um information on what i did within the
ise domain team i want to just give a
little bit of an overview of the
different areas within
n3c that i was involved in
the two main areas being
being part of the group of individuals
that
worked with the actual data
and also the publication committee
um the focus of my presentation today
will be on the
um
my involvement in working with the data
now specifically
filling the role of an information
and
my understanding of
the work that implementations do
i understand that they do a wide range
of different
tasks
from researching data
um creating uh cohorts and creating data
set templates
and um
that is the role that i will be
um talking about that i was involved in
and so
the n3c immunosuppressed and compromised
population clinical domain team
was the domain team that i was
involved in
during this internship
um
their objective is to gain a better
understanding of how cova-19
affects patient populations with
suppressed or compromised immune systems
and
the
ic domain team consists of five sub sub
domain teams
um
those are rheumatoid
rheumatoid arthritis or lupus
uh human immunodeficiency
virus or hiv
a solid organ transplant
multiple sclerosis
and the subdomain team that i worked
the closest with was the autoimmune skin
disorders domain team
um
and so just to
um reiterate what my role is and be a
little bit more specific about it
um
part of
my learning of team science and um
the work that i did within the domain
team
was the processing of raw data from
the institutions to organize data
and
my
work that i did was
importing the already organized data
done by the other informations into
a
space to then
do more work on that data
and so to give a little bit of
an example of what an information might
do
is this is
a fake data by the way um
and so
this is an example of
raw data that you would find in the um
n3c
data enclave and as you can see it's not
very helpful in
being specific and
pulling certain information
um
some of it also doesn't have all the
information for all the different um
patients
and so this was not um a great
data set to use
when
running statistical analysis and
determining significant um
statistics
for clinicians to
um
uh write about and get to the public
and so
the informations can then
uh through a multi-step process as i've
uh learned
um take the raw data
and
um
make it into
a
more organized data set that for example
could look like this
where
you can identify if the person got the
vaccine or not
um
when they got it
um
what
kind of what type of vaccine did they
get and
if they got their second vaccine um
and so they and
then they can also
create the data set where it'll tell you
if they did
not also get the
um vaccine
and
um
so this is a crucial step in the process
this was not my area of involvement
um
so the data that from
uh
the data that is now organized into a
data set needs to then be put into a
place where
transformations between different data
sets can occur
and
that is this is where all the magic
happens in n3c it's called
and maybe other
workspaces as well
it's called a workbook and the concept
of the workbook is
being able to
import multiple different data sets
and
essentially you can pull
certain information from the different
data sets
um to
produce a new data set
and so
the components of a workbook are the
data set
that you created uh example shown on the
previous slide
and through transformations
code to pull
a certain information
from these
data sets and create
a
query
that
can then be combined with multiple more
different data sets and
have a final result of
a data set that has all of the different
information
for
saying the same patients
which is the um
work that i did for the isc domain team
apologies it's very small
[Music]
so as i mentioned in the beginning there
are five subdomain teams within the iec
domain team
at the time that i started working with
the vaccination data four of the five
subdomain team data sets had already
been
imported into the workbook
as you can see there are four of the
five here
and
what i did was add the
fifth subdomain team uh
data set which is the autoimmune
skin disorders um
cohort
data set
and
code to pull the specific information
that um
from this cohort and relate it back to
the many other transformations within
this um
a workbook
and in doing so it was helpful because
it would then
populate to the
master
um
data set
indicated by the pink arrow here
that has all the information and data
for
all five sub-domain
teams within isc domain team
all the information on the
all the vaccination information for all
the patients
and so
that
would be helpful then
um if they were working another workbook
they could then import that data and
know that
the information for
any of the sub domain teams
the vaccination data would be within
there
and that is
helpful to make the process of
importing data easier on those
individuals
which is the other thing that i helped
with
this is the
autoimmune skin disorders workbook and
what they wanted to do was combine
vaccination data on those
patients
with the
um
same info with the information on those
same patients with a different data set
that had a different
um
different type of information
and so to do so
um
i used our programming
that is within the
workbook
i'm use the merge function
um to basically tell it to um take all
the information in
this uh
data set by the green arrow
um take all that information um
but only take
asd
related information from the data set
indicated in the yellow
arrow and of course it is data and
as i mentioned n3c is a very large
um
initiative and there's tons of data
and so i ran into errors of course um
the first era wrench was ram
and
essentially my laptop wasn't able to
um
successfully
run the code because the
merging of the two data sets was too
large
and
to work around it we
try to use different our
programming languages such as
spark r and
sql
but then another error
arised there were duplicate columns
and
we
then had to reevaluate
exactly what we really wanted to
have in this
data set
as a result of the merging of these two
data sets
which
was an interesting process
to learn
and
um
the result of the merging of these two
data tables was helpful for
this
autoimmune skin disorder
sub domain team
so that they had a data table with all
of the
information the vaccination information
as well as
information
for those patients that were within this
other data
set
and so i don't have a
graph but this is the visual that i
think
worked best to illustrate
um
the result of the merge function um
so all the
information that was in the one
data set
um is then combined with the other the
information in the
um
other data set and they can become one
data table
which um is easier for um
doing things like statistical analysis
tests and
testing to see uh the significance
rather than doing it on
two separate data tables
and so
to
show the
results of
um
the
data set that had all the vaccination
information for all five sub domain
teams
um
i created
the
[Music]
uh these uh graphs in excel and all this
data has been improved um just to make
note of that
um
and so to kind of go through one of
these graphs
or excuse me bar graphs
um
on top left corner of the asd
cohort population
um
it's showing
how many people
have
gotten the full vaccine
for each of these different types of
vaccine
out of the
um of course the entire cohort
um
one thing i want to point out is this
null apologies is also very small uh the
null
here that null is the number of
individuals that
um
got their first dose of their vaccine
but did not get the second dose
of their vaccine um
and having this um information knowing
how many people
have
gotten their posts first but not second
dose of their vaccine
could
potentially be um a question to address
in
work that
these sub domain teams might want to um
delve into in the future
um and so this is a
representation of
the
how many individuals
um
this is showcasing the
entire cohort of individuals within the
entire
um
enthusiastic data enclave that
um have been marked for getting uh the
vaccine the first
or second or are both um
and so similarly in the
previous
uh graph
it a previous slide is showing um
the number of
individuals per the type of
vaccine
um
that got these uh each of these vaccines
and the first graph is showing um just
how many people got the first dose
and the second graph on the right is
showing
um
same thing except that the null
um like in the graphs on the previous
slide
um the number of individuals that did
not get their uh second
um
vaccine
and
one thing i'd like to note
um
for both the data on the previous slide
and this slide is that
it's only
information for individuals that got the
mrna and the johnson johnson vaccine
but also
one thing to note um
about the
number of individuals that i've been
marked for
getting
uh the vaccine um as you can see is
4 17 000 around about 417 000
and
the
um as of right now the
total number of
patients in the ntc data enclave is
around 6 million
and so
one thing um i guess about hr data that
can sort of be a caveat um
uh is that
it's from uh clinics and hospitals um
and so the m3c data is um from various
institutions
um but there are they are um hospital
and clinic
um
data
sets and there are from those um types
of institutions
in terms of like the covid 19 vaccine i
believe many individuals
got their vaccine
from
places within their area it'd be at
their church or
walgreens or walmart
and that
data i believe is not recorded in within
the m3c
um so just to wrap up my presentation i
want to
um
talk a little bit about reflection on
my experience with the internship
especially working with data
prior to this internship i had no
experience whatsoever with
working with data or coding even
and so
i now understand that coding is a very
um essential element to data on being
able to process data
and um
get from a to z and
um being able to pull into specific data
and
um
to have that be
um analyzed and interpreted and
um it's just an essential skill um
for
team science um but also
um anyone going into data i
believe
and um as anita said uh n3c is um
a
huge like collaboration so there is
obviously a team science
aspect there and reflection
to the main um
uh
the two main uh aspects of team science
that i
um gained the most perspective
from are uh
program management in which related to
leadership i believe and
communication between the different
roles in one
team
and
uh program management has allowed me to
gain a different perspective on you know
what
a team needs and like what a leader
needs to be for their team
um
um
is more than um just making sure
everybody is on the same page um
as i have
learned um
and of course the communication between
the informations and the clinicians
about
what
data do they do the clinicians need for
answering the clinical question and
what the process of that is like
and so i just want to
uh
do acknowledgements and some thank yous
um
first first of all uh thank you
to ohsu
department of medical informatics and
clinical epidemiology for this
opportunity
and to gain some exposure in data
science and team silence as well
um thank you to anita walden my mentor
for
being great support during the entire
internship um
and uh answering my questions of course
and thank you to sean o'neill
he answered
my
r programming related questions
um
and thank you to amy olex who worked
closely with me with the vaccination
data
and helped me with
that process and understanding
of
informatics on a deeper level
and
uh lastly thank you of course the ntc
isc domain team
for
letting me sit in in their meetings and
observe
the different dynamics to gain a better
understanding of team science as well
and
that is all thank you
thank you gabriella
are there any questions or comments
hello
hi gabriella it's amy
oh hi amy
hey nice presentation good job um
i know you came into this internship
with um not much data analysis
experience so i was wondering if um you
reflect and uh
maybe tell those who may be interested
in doing this type of work but don't
have any data experience um
i guess what the biggest challenges that
you had to overcome in order to complete
this internship
yeah um
yeah um as uh amy was saying i
came in with
no
background in
anything that is essential to data
science which isn't a bad thing it was a
good experience to get that exposure
um i would say one of the main
challenges was since my role with the
ise domain team was
um information
um
while i did study r
um applying it to actual data was a
little more tricky than um i thought it
was going to be
um
it's i think that parts of
uh data
applying
um
what you're reading and
practicing is kind of difficult um
and also
learning my way around
um
the workbooks that were already in set
understanding
uh
their coding what they were pulling was
um
kind of difficult and um
an interesting process but
um
i would say that was probably the
biggest challenge
is to
kind of familiarize myself with the
different
um workbooks and ways that the different
um informations did their work
thank you
of course thank you
any other questions or comments
well i have a comment gabrielle i would
say that you're brave
not to have you know experience and
income into this world it can be
overwhelming but um i i appreciate your
bravery and your courage and jumping in
there and
and um you know willing to learn and so
um
thank you so much it's been great having
you you know this summer
well thank you for this opportunity
okay
all right if there are no other
questions um we'll bring up the next
speaker
all right our next speaker is make a
name he's from um beaverton oregon and
attends the university of oregon
and i think you're a sophomore you might
be a junior now a sophomore
at oregon um university of oregon so
nathan um you know came does he does
have a little bit experience this is
great because all three interns actually
you know work together and collaborate
together too and so he was able to you
know also help answer questions you know
for the other interns when it came to
some of the programming languages
and so um nathan's going to talk about
his work um
an area of data science that he worked
in the summer
all right we can see your slides nathan
but we can't hear you yet you're you're
muted if you're speaking
you're still muted yeah
oh okay my bad can you hear me now now
we can hear you all right all right cool
yeah so
uh i'm nathan ing and like gabriella i
was
one of
anita's interns and i want to talk
specifically about data visualization
and
challenges of team science
so just some
brief background about my internship i
was involved
in n3c which is the national covid
cohort collaborative
essentially a group of researchers
interested in
covet data and more specifically
um
i believe that my intro my internship
would uh revolve around long covid which
is
just covid cases where um
people are experiencing covet longer
than the
estimated three weeks um however my
internship quickly
pivoted to focus on various other
projects
and a lot of the work that i did this
summer was um
centered around r which is a programming
language and so the two projects that i
specifically want to talk about are data
cleaning and templates
uh
data cleaning is crucial in
the world of data analysis because
without it it's a lot harder for
researchers to understand the data
they're working with and so this
screenshot is from the home page of the
enclave
the enclave is essentially a database or
a server of all of the data
um and tools available to researchers
and
scientists
uh regarding kovid and so uh it's kind
of hard to see in this picture but there
are 7.8 billion total rows of data
and this data isn't necessarily all from
you know one data set this is from
hundreds and thousands of data sets and
so
cleaning up that data and making it more
usable um
and reader friendly is crucial in
understanding patterns and trends in the
data
and so more specifically uh some of the
data cleaning that i was involved with
are involved in
was for the social determinants of
health domain team
and more specifically the census data
which is also known as dpo2 or selected
social characteristics in the u.s and so
something important to note is that this
isn't actually a true
uh like a true census that actually
occurs every 10 years instead this is
called acs census data which is data
that's calculated
from the previous five years and so
all of these calculations are estimates
and this is actually an external data
set and so that's something important to
mention about the enclave is not only
does it include
the actual data
on covid patients itself but there's
also external data sets which are
utilized to aid researchers
in their projects and so this was
actually a repurposed data set it was
originally intended to get to gather uh
demography information to inform
political representation
however it's now being repo repurposed
towards uh kova research
and so just a little more about this uh
specific
data set it's kind of you can't actually
see the entire data set because it's
much too large to fit on
this slide but there are 614 columns and
over 3000 rows with over 10 different
variables
and um
the unfortunate thing about the enclave
is that
it has a limited number of packages
available to
um
to the developers and so a package is
essentially just
a library
is also another way you can call it but
it's just um
previous code the other
people have developed and so there are
actually solutions to clean up data sets
uh
in
normal r however you can't actually use
all of these solutions in the enclave so
that's some that's some of the work i
had to do i had to uh create a method of
data cleaning and so before i talk about
that just a brief overview of this um
of this of the census table so
each row represents a different county
and then the top we have these codes
which correspond to a statistic and
a specific variable so taking a closer
look
at that at these variables
this is an example of one of them so the
the first uh
the first
part of this variable is the statistic
type so in this case it's an estimate
but it could also be a margin of error
percent percent error so on and so forth
then uh we have the category so in this
case ancestry
then um following that are subcategories
so in this case we have total population
and
portuguese and so
you'll notice that each of the
each of these different categories are
separated by two exclamation marks which
is important
for
finding the pattern and cleaning this up
also
in this in this uh image i tried to
illustrate
how a lot of times researchers are
interested in not the whole data set but
just part of the data set so for example
a researcher
might be interested in computers and
internet use that's
that could illustrate some economic
uh economic trends among households they
might be interested in educational
attainment so those are some examples of
how
a researcher might be interested in
looking at a specific part of this data
set
so i'll just quickly kind of run through
this this is the logic behind
a um script i wrote that will
clean up this data set by filtering
through
and only
and
creating a data set with the
uh variables of interest so
i just have some quick
guides so we start off by importing a
library which again contains uh one of
the necessary functions that we're
interested in this function
basically takes in the data itself the
metadata which again has the raw codes
that i previously mentioned
you know which is in this format dp02
underscore followed by some digits
and it also has the corresponding um
variable format with like the x double
exclamation marks and then lastly a list
of the variables that we would like to
extract and so
essentially the rest of this logic
just filters through and at the end we
return
the transform data frame so what this
actually
would look like utilizing it uh we just
can call the function um
right here we have the
data file the metadata and then we have
a
list of two different
variables that we want to pull out and
these two are identical
the function is set up so you can use
either one
and so
for example in this in this case this
was extracting all of the variables with
related to educational attainment
um instead of the
i believe it was 614 columns before this
one only has 10 total columns which
is just creating a more concise data
frame um which is easier to
to visualize uh for the future so this
is still a project i'm working on i
actually still have a week and a half of
my internship left and so the next steps
um
in this data cleaning process is uh
creating visualizations for this however
that's where templates come into play
which is the other major project i've
been working on um templates help clean
and visualize data and allow
allow other researchers to save time
because they no longer have to invent
the real invent the wheel um much as the
name suggests and these are more user
friendly uh not everyone in these
different teams or
um
not everyone in these different teams
such as the social determinants of
health the main team have the same uh
the same programming or technical uh
expertise as other users not to say that
they're you know they're not super
talented and skilled it's just not
everyone has the same skill set and so
the fact that these
they don't really need to have
um a coding background to utilize
templates really helps
streamline the process of data cleaning
and so uh
templates are utilized in a tool called
code workbooks which is
a tool you can researchers have access
to in the enclave again the enclave is
just the server or website where all of
the data and
and resources are stored for
researchers and so
the setup of a code workbook is a node
setup so each of these
boxes represents a different node and
the arrows
represent like a transfer a connection
so for example this is the original data
set
and then we have a transformation that
takes place
and another one
we can also we can also visualize with
graphs and this is again where templates
come into play
so the major uh template that i was
involved in is a single date frequency
plot
this one is specifically grouped by data
partner id and so
a lot of the data
or all of the data in the enclave is
contributed
through is contributed to
by multiple institutions and
organizations
because obviously just data from one
hospital does not represent the entire
us and so
in this example
this
in this example the the frequency plot
is split up by uh data partner id and so
this is synthetic data uh which means
it's not like
true real data which is why uh the
x-axis is a little off but essentially
what this graph
is graphing is on the x-axis we have the
procedure date and then on the y-axis we
have the count and the number of times
that procedure
has been recorded and then each of these
lines
it might be a little hard to see but
they correspond to a different procedure
type
and so
just a closer look at what that input
data looks like
the
two
uh columns of interest and for me were
procedure date because again
uh we wanted to see
when those procedures were happening and
also the
procedure concept name because that lets
us determine the frequency
of the or the count of the procedures so
each of these rows represent
a different
uh individual
and so now just quickly running through
the logic behind that uh frequency plot
uh essentially this top part this top
block right here um
does a little bit of cleanup so there
are actually over 120 different
over 120 different procedures in this
example and so an issue i ran into was
that rather than showing the graph the
legend was just clogged with all of the
procedure names and so
instead i
only took the 10 largest occurrences or
10 most common procedures and then i
grouped everything else as other
and then
this
logic right here is just uh graphing
logic uh which again produced that
frequency plot
uh and so as far as template creation
goes it's pretty simple once you've
created your um base code uh you're
given this interface where you can input
placeholder variables where
you know
from there
future
users of the template can plug in their
own values because keep in mind not
every single
data set has the exact same
convention
in terms of naming
and so utilizing a template is extremely
easy
while you're in the code workbook if you
hover over
any of your nodes there's a plus icon
that appears
then it's again it's really hard to see
so my bad but uh from there you can
select the transform type and templates
is one of the option and then you can
browse all of the templates available
and if you know the name of the template
you're looking for like
you can filter through templates so for
example if i knew i wanted the single
day frequency plot i could just type
that in and it would appear and be
ready for use
so again to reiterate
uh templates are extremely important in
the pre-processing
aspect of data because they help us save
time and
additionally they're reusable and
all a template is is um
creating code that's easily uh
it's essential a template just makes it
so that we can reuse logic and it's not
hard coded in to fit one
specific task instead it can be reused
and redistributed among other
projects in the future
and so the main challenges that i faced
in terms of just these projects in the
internship in general it was just
finding a way to be efficient with the
data again the
scale of the data is extremely large and
so
whether it was
within the actual
script that i was writing just trying to
find ways where i could save time and
then also just the fact that you know
again all of these different data sets
have different
formats and
uh
and layouts just finding something that
can address as many as possible um is
definitely difficult there are also
variations in health diagnosis codes so
uh an example from a meeting that i had
in the past
regarding long covid there were
several institutions that had a variable
um
called uh
brain fog which is just a symptom that
us
students were sorry not students that uh
the patients were experiencing
and the
uh diagnosis code was
proprietary proprietary or different in
a lot of these uh different healthcare
systems that were contributing data so
um connecting the dots is
can be difficult sometimes
i was also involved in multiple projects
all going in different directions so
time management was definitely a major
factor
learning a new language
not only r but also learning the
technical terms was definitely a
challenge um the thing about analyzing
and cleaning up these data sets is that
although you don't need to
although i wasn't responsible for
you know truly interpreting what all
these data sets mean
i still had to understand at a basic
level
uh the different technical terms and so
it did take some time
getting
to know those uh
and familiarize
it did take some time to familiarize
myself with those and then lastly time
was uh definitely an issue in terms of
getting registered for the enclave
there's obviously a strict code of
conduct in order to have to gain access
to this data because
you know it crea it contains
it contains uh
you know records that are very private
and so it did take
much longer than i had hoped to
receive access to this uh which made it
you know it wasn't as convenient
for sure
but
uh all in all i did have
all in all i did have some great
outcomes when it comes to this
internship again i learned r which was
not a language i'd ever looked at before
i also
learned a lot about what it's like to be
in a team where
the skills are
greatly varying and i had never been in
a team science environment before so
that was definitely super interesting
and of course i also improved my stats
knowledge in the process
moving forward i plan to continue
working on templates the next template i
want to work on is actually a date range
template so the template that i
shared which was a single date frequency
plot
you know procedure date is something
that's occurring one time however a date
range might be for example when someone
is diagnosed with covid plus or minus 90
days and so i want to
create a template which deals with that
kind of data i also am going to continue
data cleaning with
the census
data and so the next steps are census
visualization and lastly i am working on
a project with dr jeremy harper which is
specifically focused on long covid which
again was what the roots of my
internship
were supposed to cover so i'm looking
forward to that
and
i just wanted to give a special thanks
to the following people as
they
were crucial in my learning experience
this summer and i could not have
done this without them
so thank you for listening
thank you nathan
are there any questions or comments
hi nathan i have one
can you hear me okay we can hear you
yeah yep
um you know i know that you you uh came
to n3c with some some technical skills
in python you know you're in i believe
you're in computer science department
but you've also rapidly picked up a lot
of new technologies around r and
everything in the enclave and i was
curious if you had any sort of um
any sort of high level thoughts about
strategies that you use to pick up you
know new technical stuff at a rapid clip
and things you might share with others
based on your experience
yeah i would say that
um like i said i was involved in a lot
of different projects and so
uh anytime that
anita would ask me if i wanted to step
in on something else i would just say
yes because
it was it helped uh create more exposure
and get used to these tools also a lot
of the
[Music]
i'd done some data analysis in python
previously and so a lot of the
fundamental fundamentals carry over um
and so i would just kind of connect can
i kind of connect the dots from there
and then also the textbook that you
provided was
was really straightforward and clear so
just going through that was definitely
helpful
thank you are there any other questions
so i have a question for you nathan so
um
the the templates that you're creating
well those those are going to be
available are they going to be placed
into the knowledge store so they're
available to other researchers for them
to use uh
yeah as far as i know
obviously i don't think they're
available yet but yeah i will be
uploading them there
okay and then another related question
to that are there any standard practices
for the type of data cleaning that
you're doing um that can be applied you
know across the board like you know can
you take and replicate that so people
are not recreating the will
um
i'd have to get i'm not sure about that
yeah
all right well thank you so much um i
and also thank you for all the work that
you've been doing i mean there's a lot
of things that you talked about and
there are things that there's more to
your internship than just that and so i
definitely want to extend my thanks for
being willing to jump in and help out
whenever needed and um and pick up other
skills
yeah thank you as well
all right so um
the next person that's going to speak
will be
oregon islamic academy she's um a rising
senior or as a senior um in high school
and so muna um luna is very passionate
about helping people so she participated
um on a social determinants of health um
domain team this summer and worked with
them on her internship so um when i'm
gonna turn things over to you
are you able to get your slides up there
we go it looks like something's starting
to happen there we go you can see yeah
okay
hello everyone um my name is mona i am a
senior at oregon islamic academy
and i'm also an n3c intern and today i'm
going to be talking about the
exploration of data science and
visualization for social determinants of
health and cover 19 data
so i'm going to be talking about five
main points in my presentation which is
social determinants of health
data science and health care programming
with our data visualization options and
data cleaning
so n3c domain teams allow researchers
with similar interests to examine data
in the n3c enclave and work more
effectively in a team science setting
and these teams allow participants to
collect pilot data for grant proposals
guide clinical
uh trials design
and learn how to use
large size covet data and validate
results
so in total there is 31 domain teams
looking at different aspects of kovid
and i got to work with one team
specifically which is social
determinants of health
so with the intersection of health care
and data science is merging the era of
health care research and operations
analysis researchers and data scientists
in the field can really take advantage
of the increasing demands for
opportunities
data science blends the unique skills of
unlocking
unlocking enhance of data and
storytelling so when i first came into
this internship i only knew the term
data science so i didn't really
understand
the tools behind it or the types
so during this internship i was able to
practice some of these types which is
data visualization and data cleaning
social so social determinants of health
are known fact non-medical factors that
influence health care influence health
outcomes they are conditions in which
people are born grow
work live and age
in a wider
set of forces systems shaping the
conditions of daily life these forces
and systems include economic policy
system development agendas social norms
and
for the social determinants of health
demanding they really focus on five main
types of social terms of health which is
economics education healthcare
neighborhood and built environments and
social and
community contexts
so i got to work with this domain team
and they have three main leaders i got
to work with two specifically
and they have 22 collaborating sites to
represent the united states
so the social determinants of fellow
domain team goal is to identify at least
three questions that either validate
through current research or answer new
questions for the following categories
um local policies around cover 19
impacts
groups experiences
resources challenges and impacts
of the pandemic on inequalities
so
when i first joined this team i was
really interested in literature review
so uh i was given the task to actually
go through the process so what they
wanted me to do is i looked through
papers
and i was
given the task to identify papers that
met the social terms of
social determinants of health
requirements which is the articles need
to be
studied
that's to study equivalent 19 county
levels and have death counts
that's to analyze counties in the united
states not just coming from one state
and it has to have a socio-economic
status and county characteristics
characteristics as an independent
variable
and they also have to include key
concepts which is county characteristics
social demographics and health status
and many others
so
in total i reviewed 147 articles
and then from there i went to read 30
articles in depth
trying to find the key concepts but in
total i only found seven that meant the
full requirement
and out of those seven i am going to
present two which i found really
interesting
they helped me get a better
understanding of social determinants of
health
and they
really are interesting articles and the
first article is social determinants of
health mortality of covenant 19 and
basically this study found
disproportionate burdens on
racial and ethnic minorities the poor
those with less education
and veterans and using the national
health
and nutrition examination survey data
from 2017 and 2018 they calculated the
proportion of
carbon 19 fetal teas
and demographics for the general
population
they mentioned that the public health
initiative should target these
populations explicitly and
the data social factors should be
collected consistently from the patients
so in this
data visualization
it shows uh
the disproportion the distribution
of uh features of the simulation coca-19
fatalities and characteristics from
their comparator
population
from the national health nutrition
examination survey
and as a result the simulation confirms
that the general trends disproportionate
fatalities among the elderly and through
it shows a greater number of deaths at a
younger age
so the second article i reviewed is
association of
social determinants of health with
kevin 19 moralities and basically in
this uh
in this study it show looked at
rural and urban counties death rates per
100 000
which were sub
substantially related to the percentage
of
blacks hiv
diabetes and employment and the study
examined county levels
uh social determinants of health
characteristics that were linked higher
and lower covered 19 morality rates
and it revealed a clustered of counties
that were at higher risk of dying
and in this visualization you can see
that it shows
um the estimated morality per hundred
thousand
luna i'm going to pause just a second
your slides are not very clear
um
do you mind stop sharing sharing again
see if that might work looks like
there's a something
[Music]
can you see it better now
that it's coming up for me
um okay maybe this is the way to slice
look okay never mind then go ahead
okay
so programming with r so r is a
programming language um for performing
data research
r is
it's a statistical programming and
graphics programming language
and that is used for cleaning analyzing
uh graphing data
r is considerably the most fertile uh
versatile language for supporting
interactive than many uh
languages
and
this is an example of programming with r
i used r studios to
code this and
in the corner you can see uh
an example of data visualization and
data visualization is a tool
that gives an easy method to examine and
analyze trends outer layers and patterns
and data and these visualizations
accelerate research and data processing
by combining user friendly and visual
attractive elements
they serve also a strong communication
tool and data visualization tools
also include visual components like
charts graphs and maps
and this is an example of geospatial
maps they are commonly used in
data science research and i previously
showed it in one of the articles but
this is an another example you can see
that there are a lot of tiny spaces and
each space represent a county
and usually these maps are either 3d or
interactive but this is just an example
of a 2d map
so this is a bubble chart also known as
a bubble plot they're also used in
switzerland's field there are an
extension of scatter plots
used to look at relationships between
three numeric values each
each dot of a chart represents a single
data point and in this case
like it represents a country
and
um
and in the variable values for each
point it indicates a horizontal vertical
position and a dot size
so data cleaning so before a
researcher can actually use data they
have to go through data pre-processing
which is data cleaning data
transformation and data reduction
and
basically what
is the most important is data cleaning
and it's like the most important step in
data processing because it makes it
easier for a researcher to read the data
and in this domain team's case not a lot
of them are
not a lot of them are coders or
programmers so data cleaning really
helps them with their research
so in conclusion
i was able to get a practical experience
with data and during my internship i
gained a better grasp of data science
and learn new topics like r social
determinants of health data
visualization and data cleaning
and i was able to connect with these
researchers and develop a relationship
with them
and this internship provided me
a valuable experience that will serve me
in the world
and serve me well in the near future
and i would like to thank my mentors for
helping me in this uh internship and
teaching me new things
and hear my sources
thank you
all right thank you
are there any questions
or comments
so i have a question luna um so you you
reviewed articles how many articles did
you say you reviewed
147 147 how many of those
actually
were um useful to the or answer the
questions the three questions for the
social demistic health group
um seven
seven okay
all right that's those articles
so um another question is related to
that is that um i know you are trying to
answer those three questions and so
that's what your focus is on um since
you're new to this area and new social
determinants of health while you were
reviewing the articles did were there
any other questions that came up to you
you know and that you felt like maybe
this should be a question that the
social social terms of healthcare should
consider
um
looking at some of the articles like i
had a few questions like whether some
parts actually fit in social terms of
health but
actually learning about it through the
article to help me like understand it
better
um i did come up with some questions
that i
thought would be interesting but it
didn't really lie under the social
determinants of health category but it
was nice learning
about these things
okay and what kind of questions were
those that you that you felt that you
thought perhaps it could be social terms
appeal or that were interesting to you
um
i mean
when i previously talked about education
i was thinking of like how it affects
both teachers and students like how
their environment is
and it does lie under uh social terms of
health but in some of the articles it
doesn't really like mention that so i
developed a question out of the article
and after discussing with them and them
explaining how
social terms work it taught me that like
it didn't
really lie underneath that that's more
of something else but
that's like one of them that i thought
about
okay
all right terrific
can i ask a quick question
sure
hi this is chris i'm one of the
librarians at ohsu really nice talk
i was surprised the first paper that you
showed to us was actually a simulation
study kind of in and of itself
just the idea that everybody's trying to
use data in different ways through
simulation and other things to kind of
make their arguments
and i was curious you you know you
showed us two out of seven were any of
the other papers also simulation studies
people trying to kind of
you know use other data sources to work
with covid or were all the other papers
like the second one you showed us where
they were kind of using
um they weren't using simulation thank
you
um
i'm trying to remember all of them but i
remember two of them were simulations
one of
the one i showed and another one but
majority of them were just like the
second article
and i think it's interesting with covid
especially with the literature around
covid that there's so much literature
about people trying to forecast and
simulate and get ahead of things that i
wonder when people continue on with
projects and like this in the future
whether they'll see there's like this
cluster of um simulation papers and then
they'll have the papers that we actually
did later and we'll be able to see how
well the simulations kind of compare
that's an interesting question for later
anyway thank you very much
any other questions
all right luna thank you so much um i'm
glad you um
you know we're able to work with the
social terms of health group and learn a
little bit more especially since you're
passionate about helping people um and
hopefully you'll continue along that
path
all right um
i think that's it from our end
yep i think that'll be it for today
thank you everyone for
showing up and listening to our
presentations
all right thank you thank you
thank you